okay let's get started
uh welcome back so we're gonna continue
on to lecture seven today and
topic for today is going to be
generative learning algorithms
so the plan for today is to is to
cover gaussian discriminant analysis gda
this is also on your homework and then
move on to naive bayes
another generative learning algorithm
and before we dive into
generative models let's look at what we
have covered so far so so far we have
covered
linear regression logistic regression
and generalized linear models
all three of these are what you may call
discriminative algorithms
we call them discriminative algorithms
because uh they directly model p of y
given x
where y is the desired output and x is
the input right and supervised learning
in the supervised learning setting we
are interested in learning map mappings
from x to y
and when y given x is assumed to be a
normal
distribution what we get as a
consequence is linear regression
and when y given x is assumed to be
bernoulli as a consequence we get
logistic regression and when y given x
is assumed to be in the exponential
family we get generalized linear models
and we saw that generalized linear
models is a broad
family and it includes normal and
bernoulli as special cases so linear
regression and logistic regression are
special cases of
generalized linear models and now
right now we are going to
start focusing on x
in discriminative algorithms x is
assumed to be given
in fact when we were looking at these
at these methods each of the x j
features or attributes could have been
real valued could have been integer
valued could have been booleans
and we were kind of agnostic to it right
but now we are going to focus on
x and
we will model
p of x comma y
instead of modeling p of y given x that
was the conditional distribution
we are now going to model p of x comma y
that is the full joint distribution
right and this ah joint distribution
is also commonly called as the model
right and we see that this can be
factorized using the chain rule of
probability
into p of x given y
times p of y
right and p of y is also
commonly called as the class prior
why is it called the class class prior
so the
we will be focusing mostly on the cases
where
y is discrete valued which means
these generative models uh that we're
going to uh discuss today gaussian
discriminant analysis and naive bayes
are are best suited for classification
problems
ah so why is is is um
indicates the class of an of a given
example and p
of y is just the marginal probability of
of um
of of y and the class prior generally
um you think of it as
what is the fraction of examples which
belong to a particular class without
even looking at
you know the x features you know overall
in your in your population
what fraction of your examples belong to
a particular class
right and
p of x given y is generally high
dimensional
right so p of y given x
in in these ah in these two examples
y was a scalar it's either a real value
or a
zero or one right whereas generally p of
x given y
is high dimensional where x is the set
of all your features right
and and so p of x given y we are trying
to model
um a high high dimensional probability
distribution
uh because your your features can be
very high valued and that's in general
a harder problem high dimensional
probability is uh
in general uh um harder both for
you know analytical and computational
reasons yes questions
right so the question is um you know why
do we want to do
uh generative modeling why do we want to
model p of x because x is generally
given to us is that the question
yeah so uh there are a few reasons why
you want to do this and
uh we will we will touch upon that
towards the end of gaussian discriminant
analysis you know
at this point we will kind of compare
you know
when we want to do one versus the
another and that may be a good time to
kind of re-ask that question
um right so this is
so we want to model p of um x given y
and at prediction time
when we want to make a prediction on on
a new example x test that is given to us
so p of y given x where x is like a new
new example
we can use the bayes rule to
swap it around this will be p of x given
y
times p of y over
p of x right p of x given y and p of y
are our is the direct
chain rule expansion of the joint and we
get a p of
x in the denominator and this can also
um
generally in cases when y is
is a binary we can write this as p
of x given y times
p of y over
p of x given y equals 0 time
p of y equals 0 plus
p of x given y equals 1 times
p of y equals 1 right
and and we can write it this way because
p of x
is exactly equal to this when y is ah
twice binary right so this is the
the base rule to get p of y given x and
p
of y given x is generally called the
posterior distribution
and when we want to make a prediction as
a class
rather than a probability right so p of
y given x will give you the probability
of say
y equals 1 given x or y equals 0 given x
but when we want to make a prediction of
whether
example x belongs to the class y equals
0 or y equals 1
we generally do it this way so y
hat equals
arc max of y
p of y given x
right which is the y that has the
highest posterior probability does
y equals zero have a higher probability
or this y equals one have a higher
posterior probability
right and this is this is a the the
the common recipe for making predictions
whether we are
using gaussian discriminant analysis or
naive bayes or you know any generative
model
ah in general and in order to do this
prediction you may observe that
p of y given x you can write it like
this p of ah
this is the r max or y
and p of y given x was
p of x given y p of
y over p of x
in order to calculate the arg max over y
we observe that p of x the denominator
is just some constant and it is going to
evaluate to the same value
for the cases of y equals 0 and for the
case of y equals 1
which means this is the same as
r max over y p of
x given y times p of y
right so ah for the purposes of making
a prediction of which
class we want to assign an example to we
do not even have to calculate the
denominator
yes yes
yeah so the question is you know p of y
has has
meaningful interpretation you can think
of it as a fraction of examples that are
positive
you know what what does p of x mean
right and p of x means
it can mean different things in
different problems
so p of x you can think of it as what's
the probability that you're going to
encounter
this example this input
in your population right that's one way
to think of it
and um it could have you know um it
could be it could belong to class 0 or
class 1
but you're you know given in a given um
an input example
you know you're trying to answer the
question what's the probability of
encountering
that input right
that's that's a rough intuition yes
what's the significance of maximizing y
so um
what we are calculating here is
we are trying to find out which value of
y results in the highest posterior
probability
because we want to we want to consider
that value of y
as our prediction
that make sense
so ah if our goal is to just make a
decision
of choosing y equals 0 or y equals 1
then for that problem of making a
decision of y equals 0 or y equals 1
we don't even have to calculate the
denominator but if we want to calculate
the probability
of of y given x then we absolutely need
to calculate the denominator
right the two are different problems
right if you want to calculate the exact
probability is it 0.77 or 0.5 or 0.2
then you absolutely need to calculate
the denominator but
if your problem is to only decide
whether
probability of y equals 0 given x is
greater than or lesser than probability
of y equals 1 given x
just to do the the greater than or
lesser than you don't need the
denominator
yes question
so in this case uh the question is won't
the probability of x
a change depend on what class it came
from so in this case we have
marginalized out the class
right so you're just considering all the
examples in in one common pool
where you know you know they're mixed
with all the classes i'm just going to
pick one example at random and ask
what's the
what's the probability that you observe
the input
okay so so with in this setting
we are going to cover two different
algorithms
right two algorithms for today
and for both the algorithms
y will be discrete
right so the first algorithm is g d a
gaussian discriminant analysis
in this x is continuous
and the other algorithm you could
consider is naive base
in this x is discrete
and you know the example that we are
going to use is is a text classification
right so in discriminative algorithms
when we we we had two different kinds of
algorithms depending on whether y
was continuous or discrete or here our
focus is on x
and we're going to get two different
kinds of algorithms depending on whether
x was continuous or x was discrete but
we are limiting ourselves to this
to the case of classification only so
we're going to limit ourselves to
you know y equals uh 0 or 1 ah but
your x's can be continuous or or
discrete
and before we jump into our
first learning algorithm first g ah
jumping into gda just some terminology
um so the model
we call the joint probability of p of x
comma y as the model
so this is the joint p of
x comma y and it is common practice
to define our model or express our model
as a data generating process right
data generating process and this process
is is represented as
a hierarchy of
of steps with which we generate our
model
and this has a one to one correspondence
with the way we factorize our joint
probability
right now what does this mean let lets
see the case of
gda to to get a concrete sense of
what what we mean by this
so gda
this is our first generative model
so in gda we define the model like this
as a data generating process
so y is sampled from
bernoulli with parameter fee
and x given y is
sampled x equals y equals 0 a sample
from
a normal distribution with mean mu
naught
and covariance sigma
x given y equals 1 is sampled from
normal distribution with mean mu 1
and covariance sigma
right so this is a hierarchy of how
a hierarchy of steps with which we can
generate our data so first sample
a class variable from a bernoulli
distribution with parameter phi
that decides whether the example that we
are about to generate belongs to
the class y equals 0 or does it belong
to the class y equals 1.
and then we generate the input x given y
equals 0
according to a normal distribution with
some mean and covariance
and if y equals 1 we generate the
example as a sample from
a different normal distribution with
mean mu 1
but in this case we are sharing the
covariance matrix and and we'll go into
the details of why we do that later
but for now assume both the normal
distributions share the covariance
matrix
but have different means
and for this sequence of steps
the corresponding distributions will be
p of y equals
v y times 1 minus v to the
1 minus y and this is the bernoulli
the bernoulli distribution and
p of x given y equals 0
is equal to 1 over
2 pi to the d by 2
one half
minus half x minus mu
naught transpose
similarly p of x a plus one
ok and
here y is in 0
1 and x is in
r d right so ah
what do we have here so p of y is is a
simple
ah bernoulli and let me just write the
parameters in a different color
so these are all parameters
v and p of x given ah
y equals 0 is
parameter here
not sigma inverse mu naught
and similarly in this case
so y is is ah is discrete its either
zero or one
and depending on what y we sample
we generate an x that's the input
based on one either one of the two
gaussian distributions with different
means but they share the same covariance
structure
right so the
generative algorithms one way to think
of them is in discriminative algorithms
you are asked to differentiate
or given given an input example you are
asked to decide whether that
example belong to you know one class or
another class right
where you're kind of acting like a
critic where you know you're given an x
and you're asked to classify it as x
versus y
whereas in generative algorithms the way
you think of them is you're asked to
kind of
generate the input you're kind of here
now you're kind of acting like an artist
you're trying to come up with construct
an example x
which look different for different
different examples right
and for different classes so the the
so the goal here are kind of
different in some way where in one case
in discriminative algorithms all you are
asked to do is
have good power to discriminate whether
an example belongs to x equal y equals 0
or y equals 1
which means you may limit yourself to
just look for certain
certain cues in the input that help you
discriminate it and just ignore the rest
of
rest of the example whereas in
generative algorithms
you're asked to generate an entire
example right you're you're expected to
come up with
a full description of what makes up a
good algorithm of
a good image or a good you know
example of y equals zero or y equals one
class right so
in general uh generative model
generative modeling is uh
is a harder problem
compared to discriminative modeling
and you can also see that um because
now p of x comma y is equal to p
of y given x times p of
x which means in order to learn a
generative model you have to learn
a discriminator model and also learn
something else
right so generative modeling in general
is is a harder problem
compared to just the problem of of
learning one of the conditionals right
so this is
think of this as discriminative
and this is
generative and you have something extra
as well you know
compared to our discriminator mod yes
question
so the question is um with a generative
model uh given some
uh um training set for example we learn
how to generate new training examples
but we won't make a prediction is that
the question
so so the um so the question uh the
answer to that
is is no
because we are studying these in the
context of supervised learning which
means our
end goal at least in this part of the
course is still making predictions
right and what we are doing is that we
are learning the joint distribution
which means not only can we generate new
examples
we can also discriminate
exactly so when we want to discriminate
we will
use the bayes rule to construct a
posterior distribution
and the posterior distribution um you
know and here's a recipe to construct
the posterior distribution
using the generative modeling components
and we can use this recipe
to make predictions on new examples
all right right so um back to gda
we have defined the model like this
where y is in
um y is binary 0 or 1 x is continuous
and the the parameters of this model
parameters are
phi that belong to the ah bernoulli
mu naught that belong to uh this
distribution
mu one that belongs to
the second third distribution and sigma
that's common to both
right so first we define the data
generating process in order to
come up with with with this step you
don't need any data
right this is just math you're making an
assumption that this is the way your
data is generated
right and with this assumption we have
already defined our
probability densities we have determined
what our parameters are
and then we observe data and when we
observe data we can use the data to fit
our model
and learn these parameters using maximum
likelihood
right so
maximum likelihood
to learn parameters
right in order to ah perform maximum
likelihood
the first step is to write out the
likelihood function the or the log
likelihood function
and in this case the log likelihood
looks like this so it is the likelihood
is a function over the parameters not
the data right
a probability density is a function of
the data and assumes
ah parameters and the likelihood
is a function of the parameters phi
mu naught sigma
and this is
i equals one to n the joint
p of x i comma y i
right and this is where generative
modeling differs from
discriminative modeling right in this
primitive models we use p of y given x
and in case of generative models we use
the joint p of x comma y
and this is the key key difference
between generative models and
discriminative models in generative
models
we are interested in the joint
probability of p of x comma y
and in discriminative models we only
care about p of y given x
this questions
yeah so so the question is what's the uh
intuition about
about this and um yeah so the intuition
is
is uh exactly that what's the what's the
uh probability or
you know what probabilities wrong word
in this case
you know it's the likelihood but if you
just focus on this then you know
it's it's the probability of finding a
specific
x y pair if you just sample it from your
population of examples
so in in the the um
the analogy uh in in case of p of y
given x is
you're given an x right you had no xo is
not sampled
you know somebody gave it to you right
and now for that given x
what values of y could it possibly have
right we
we kind of limit ourselves to a universe
where we have only one example right
p of y given x and given that x
you know most of the times it could be
say y equals 1 but sometimes it can be y
equals 0 and that's your probability of
y given x
so the question in the in the
discriminative sense why did this
product make sense
so in the in the discriminative case we
had you know product i equals 1 to
n p of y i given
x i in this case for each example we are
we are assuming x got decided somehow
beyond our scope you know somebody else
decided x for us for this example
right and for and there are n such
situations where x got decided to
different values in each situation
and we are only interested in modeling y
for those specific examples right and so
here we get one probability here we get
a different probability another
probability and the joint is just
the product of them because of the
independence assumption and similarly
here
um in this case uh you know the the
joint is just the product of the
individuals because of the iid
assumption
and this we can write it as log of
i equals 1 to n now just break it down
p of x i given
y i times p of
y i and we know what
p of x i given y i and p of y i are and
they are right here so we plug them in
here
right take these take these definitions
of x given y
and p of y plug them in here
right and solve
right solve the take the log likelihood
and maximize it with respect to the
parameters
right and you get estimates for
theta of phi hat mu hat
sigma hat once you solve for the
gradient of this with respect to your
parameters equal to zero
solve for them and those are your
estimates right we've done this for
we've done this for linear regression
and you can follow something very
similar here
this question
so the uh the so the question is uh
in this case why why why don't we just
maximize the
condition of y given x right and in
order to make
to define what is y uh y given x in this
case
um going by this data generative process
you know y given x does not have a
straight answer
right so the the data generating process
only tells us what is x given y
and that's a normal right so what's y
given x here you have to apply base rule
right and in order to apply base rule
you need to be able to compute
the individual parts of the bayes rule
and in order to compute them
you need to have solve for the parameter
values
and the way we solve for the parameter
values is by doing maximum likelihood
right so maximize the joint likelihood
you get the you get the parameter values
which fit the data and then you apply
bayes rule to get your conditional p of
y given x
yes question
yeah so uh coming to that next uh was
there another question
yes
so the question is should i be dividing
by p of x over here
so so uh so the question is you know do
we need a
p of x here over here and we need the p
of
x over here only to get p of y given x
right but in generative models we are
you know for p of x comma y you don't
need a p of x in the denominator
right in generative modeling this is our
likelihood objective
right and and that's that's the
fundamental difference between
discriminative models and generative
models right in discriminative models
this will be p of y given x in which
case
you technically need a p of x here but
for generative models
we want to we want to have the ability
to
generate a new you know full
data set by just sampling from from the
model
so yeah so um
moving on so take the derivative set it
equal to zero
solve for ah solve for the different
ah parameters and what we get is
phi hat
equals 1 over n
i equals 1 to n
equal to one
you
and these are the closed form solutions
for
for if if you take this objective plug
in the
density is treated as a likelihood
differentiate take the partials with
respect to each parameter
of this entire expression set it
set the partials equal to 0 and solve
for the parameters
these are the solutions you get and this
is what is there in your homework
right yes
so uh so the question is okay so uh
let's go deeper into what what each of
these terms mean
over here we are using this this
notation
right so this is you know supposing
there's some expression here
this is basically equal to 1
if expression
is true and 0
you know if it's false right
so each of these
so y i is one for a few examples zero
for a few other examples
so here we are basically counting the
number of examples
for which y i equals 1 and dividing it
by n
so what fraction of your examples are
labeled 1
is what a phi hat will evaluate to
over here for mu naught
we are summing over those
x i's for which y i equals 0
right because
this indicator function so this notation
is called an indicator variable
so this indicator function will evaluate
to
this indicator function
will evaluate to 1 only for those
examples for which y i equals 0
so you're only summing over x i's for
which y i equals 0
and you're here you're counting the
number of examples for which y i equals
0.
right and similarly here you have you're
doing the same for
mu now what is what's what's the deal
with sigma here there are no indicator
variables here
but what we observe here is that for
each examples we are subtracting it
from the mean that is specific to that
example so we have two means
one mean for y i equals 0 and another
mean for y i equals 1.
what this means is subtract from x
the mean which belongs to its y i
this information make sense
subtract from x the mean that
corresponds to its label
right and this is basically you know um
these are the solutions and in your
homework you will be deriving it and
proving that these are
actually these solutions um which is
basically just calculus it's
um the the the computation can be a
little
um verbose but you know it's it's pretty
straightforward
and uh yeah so these are these are the
uh um
mle uh the maximum likelihood estimates
of uh the gaussian discriminant uh
analysis
so we start with defining a model
get the corresponding densities or the
probability distributions
identify what our parameters are right
write out the log likelihood objective
as the product of the joints
because that's what we model in
generative models we model the joint
distribution
and break it down into components and
the way we break down
uh broke this down as p of x given times
x given y
times p of y was because that is the
factorization that we readily have at
our hand
plug in the appropriate
densities for p of x cube y and p of y
in this likelihood objective
and take the derivative of the entire
likelihood objective with respect to the
parameters set them equal to 0
solve for them and you get these yes
question
yes this should be sigma thank you
yes questions
yeah so if we don't like indicator
functions you could for example write
this as
um
yeah yeah this is just equivalent
notation i such that
y i equals 1
of x i over summation over
i such that y i equals 1
times 1.
right so this is this just another
notation
which calculates or results in the same
same value
right here we are explicitly multiplying
some of the x's by zero and here we are
just skipping over them in the index
both for equal notations
yes questions
so the question is uh can we have um
[Music]
normal for one class poisson for another
um
i mean um you technically can you can
define your model any way you want the
question is is that
meaningful right um
a poisson is basically counts so you
know you know and a normal
is real valued so if you already know
that some of your data is
accounts belong to one class and the
data that take real values belong to
another class then you know
you kind of already you know why go
through this exercise in a way
but you know from from from a
statistical point of view you can
absolutely do that
except um you know those x's that have
poisson
must be count valued or integers
positive integers and those x belong to
the normal must be real valued
so if you have a way to kind of you know
make your math compatible with you know
some x's having a different data type
versus
other xs then yes you can you can
absolutely do that
yes questions
so the question is um in this case
will this be a a concave uh function
in this particular case i believe it is
but in general it need not be right in
general it need not be but i think in
this particular case it is
yeah so in in cases when uh so the
question is you know is this is this
concave and how can we do this without
knowing
in this case it is con concave and so
this
works in general just taking the
derivative and setting
it equal to 0 may not work but
in those cases where you know so
if if you uh it so happens
that for cases where closed form
solutions exist they tend to be concave
um and for cases where you don't have
close form solutions you tend to do
gradient ascent so you can you can you
can optimize this using gradient ascent
and in in that case you know if you are
doing gradient ascend
uh your you will reach some kind of a
local maxima
yes we're coming to that next
right so let us move on
so here we see that
by by following the above steps we we
calculate the
parameter values for the joint and using
the recipe given here you can construct
a posterior distribution for y given x
using
you know a plug in p of x given y which
is gaussian p of y
bernoulli gaussian bernoulli gaussian
bernoulli and
you will get an expression for p of y
given x
and it so happens uh that for the case
of gaussian discriminant analysis
with the c with the shared
sigma variable shared covariance
we see that the posterior distribution
takes the form of the logistic
of the logistic regression what do i
mean by that
let me write it out to make it more
concrete
right so if you go through this exercise
of calculating the posterior
distribution for
gaussian discriminant analysis we get
p of y equals 1 given x
can be written in the form one over one
plus
exp of minus theta transpose x
where theta
depends only
on mu naught mu
one phi and sigma
and this is also on your homework where
you need to where you where you show
that
uh given a gaussian discriminant
analysis
model you can represent the posterior
distribution
of y given x can be represented
in this form where theta is theta has
theta can be represented only with
ah mu naught mu one sigma and phi
right so this means the intuition to
have here is
let's assume we have one mu naught here
so here ah this this is x one
x d let us say this is
mu zero m1
use a different color for this
mu one and
they share so we have two different two
different
means each mean is specific to each
class a blue class and a red class
and the both of them share the same
covariance structure
right so if if we write out the um
the contour lines for some for for
these examples they might look like this
so these are the contour plots for the
density of class one
and these are the contour plots
for the
density of the other class and
our examples are sampled from these
gaussians so
let's say we have
similarly for the red class we have some
examples
right so we start with just the
with just the data points and
we fit a gdm model and your gdm model
would learn these to be your muse
or or values sufficiently close to be
the two muse
and the two sigmas and and the common
shared uh
covariance structure and
phi would just be the the fraction of
examples in the red and fraction of ah
to the total fraction for example and
the posterior distribution which
you can think of as the as the um
or the uh separating hyper plane which
will
which corresponds to p of y equals
1 given x equals 0.5
which is also equal to p of y equals 0
given
x so the the set of all points
x points for which the
y equals 1 class and y equals 0 class
assign
you know where the point has equal
probability of belonging to the y equals
1 class or the y equals 0 class
would be something like this
right and the the claim here is that
for any gaussian discriminant analysis
model that share the same sigma
the posterior distribution of y given x
can be represented as a logistic
regression model
where the the the thetas
only depend on on the parameters of the
model
so which means gda
any gda can be written as a logistic
regression model
now ah the reason why the two
covariance structures or the two
the two covariance structures are
similarly oriented and
similar in shape and size is because
they
you know they come off the same
covariance matrix
and these ellipsoids are
are are the shape and and orientation
and size
are completely determined by the
the covariance matrix and the principal
axes
of these covariance matrix
are basically the eigen vectors of this
covariance matrix
and the eigen values tell you how how
spread they are in each of those axes
yes question
yes the fee also decides where the hyper
plane will reside yes
the hyper plane will diff will depend on
v it's going to depend on
c mu naught mu 1 and and sigma all the
variables
exactly so so this theta over here
is is vector valued you know um and
the the uh the value of of
uh theta naught theta one theta two will
depend on will be a function of these
parameters
this question
yep
oh actually uh you're right so this
should this should
not be
yeah it shouldn't be uh it should just
be equal to it shouldn't be 0.5 you're
right
thank you
so it's a line because you can represent
it in this form and this is your
logistic regression and
you know yes there's a question
so the question is what if they have
different covariance matrices we made an
assumption that
um you're going to you're going to
assume that both the classes are going
to share the same covariance matrix
right and if if the two classes don't
have
the same covariance matrix um you can
think of it like this
right so one class will let's say is
concentrated over here
and ah
wait a second whatever i write here so
this this i i
completely messed it up sorry so this ah
the
the line that corresponds to p of
x given y equals 0 equals p
of x given y equals 1 sorry
right does that make sense the the set
of all points which have the same
density under class 1 and same and
the same density under class 0 right
that would be a straight line in this
case
in case of if we have two different
covariances
you know your examples may look like
this
right so you have some examples that are
say more concentrated here
another class examples are more
dispersed right
and in this case the set of all points
that
have the same probability under class 0
and class 1
would would actually look something like
right instead of a straight line so
these would be the set of all points
which have the same probability under
class 0
or under class 1. if both of them share
the same covariance
structure then this line will be a
straight line
and if if they are if they have unequal
covariances then
it would be it will actually it can
actually be represented as a quadratic
instead of a linear
yes you can think of it as logistic
regression with polynomial features
yeah that's one way to think of it yes
i i would encourage you to plot it and
you'll see that you know it
it's going to curve towards the the one
which is more concentrated
you know just just you know take two
covariance structures and plot the set
of points which are
which have equal probability under both
classes and it's going to come like this
any other questions okay so
a gda model for a
a given gdm model will uniquely
determine a logistic regression model
for its posterior distribution
whereas the converse is not true if you
have a logistic regression model
it may not be the posterior distribution
of a gda model
right it it could be it could it need
not be a posterior
distribution of any model or it could be
a posterior distribution of some other
model
whereas if you have a gdm model its
posterior is always a logistic
regression model
right and
the the the gda model
is making a stronger assumption in the
sense that it is making a stronger
assumption that your data is actually
distributed according to gaussian
distributions the two classes actually
have a gaussian distributions with the
shared covariance structure it is making
that assumption
now if that assumption is true then your
gdm model
will tend to be more efficient or more
asymptotically efficient or more sample
efficient compared to logistic
regression
right when when the assumption holds
true then gda is a better model
you probably need a lot fewer examples
to get
some level of accuracy compared to a
logistic regression
however logistic regression does not
make any assumption
and tends to be more robust it might
need a little more data
in cases where the assumptions are true
but it tends to work well even when you
know the assumptions are
are not met it's a pretty robust
algorithm
and in practice you know almost always
logistic regression
should probably be your first choice of
first choice of algorithm to try out on
a given data set because you know
assumptions may or may not hold true in
cases where the assumptions do hold true
gda will be slightly more efficient in
terms of
um the number of examples required
right that's that's uh and and in your
homework you will
um will also basically see um you know
um
you'll you'll be seeing you know this
phenomenon in your homework as well
when you when you um plot your data
some of which you know may be
distributed according to gaussian some
of which are not and then see your you
know the model performance between
gda and logistic regression on both
those situations all
you know all that is part of your
homework question one any questions
before we move on to knife base
yes
so under what assumptions can you map
logistic regression back to gda
the extra assumption is that your x's
are
coming from a gaussian and and having
same covariance
all right let's move on to knife base
yes so if the covariances are the same
then the
the line that has equal probability
under the two classes will be a straight
line yes
so when you solve for 1 over 1 plus e to
the minus theta transpose x
equal to 0.5 you will see that theta
transpose x must be equal to 0 so that
will be a
that'll be a line
all right naive bayes so ah
in gda we saw that the x's are real
valued they live in some
d dimensional real space
but that's generally not how or you know
um
that does not account for all the
different ways in which we encounter
data for example
our data may be you know text messages
emails and we
we may want to build a spam classifier
for
whether a given a text message or email
is
is um spam or not in those cases you
know your inputs are basically strings
where they're you know it's it's a it's
a list of words and
that doesn't fit well as you know as as
a multivariate gaussian
and so when our
x's are discrete valued
discrete that's when we use naive bayes
in order to use naive bayes x is
discrete valued most commonly we use it
for text classification
right for example spam filters
that is going to be the running example
today and this would be a good time to
review
conditional independence concept and
probability
right so conditional independence means
given two random variables x j and
x k we say they are
independent if probability of x j given
x k
equals probability of x j
right this is the definition of
independence
we say they are so this is independence
we see they are conditionally
independent
when condition on some new random
variables say y let us say
y so p of x j
given x k comma y
equals p of x j
y this is
conditional
independence when conditioned
on y right
now can anybody tell me does
independence imply conditional
independence
does conditional independence imply
and what is the answer to the first one
does independence imply conditional
independence
so does independence imply conditional
independence and does conditional
independence imply independence
yeah that's correct so both the answer
is no to both right in
in general conditional independence
your random variables could be
conditionally independent that doesn't
say anything
of whether they are independent or not
they may not be conditionally
independent and even that does not say
anything about whether
independent independent or not
conditional independence
assumes your your
assumes that both sides are conditioned
on a third variable
like y and in this case we are going to
we are going to make use of conditional
independence
and and this just this just a refresher
for what conditional independence is yes
question
so the first in naive bayes we are going
to consider two different
kind of event models the first thing the
first model that we are going to
consider is called the bernoulli event
model
so in the bernoulli event model the
mental picture to have is let us say we
have a text message
which says you know buy our lottery
right so this is a sequence of alphabets
right and we want to convert this into
some kind of
you know some kind of a vector some and
the way we do that
is to come up with what is called a
multi-hot representation where
imagine you have a long vector where
each component of the vector is
associated with some word in the
dictionary
right so let's say the first word first
component belongs to the word
a and you know if if you go through
some some dictionary here we're going to
assume english but you know
the concepts apply for anything so
second word in the dictionary would be
say aardvark
and the third was
artwolf and so on then the word by
is going to show up in your dictionary
lottery
hour and some last words
z y g m or
g y all right so some word right and
first we're going to convert
our sequence of words into a
fixed length vector where you have zeros
and places
for those words that do not appear in
the message
right and one in places where
those words do appear in in the message
right so we are going to assume
a fixed set of words which is called the
vocabulary
right and we will we assume
this vocabulary for each word to have a
fixed location
in this long vector and given a new
new input text message
we will convert it into a fixed length
vector
where we have zeros in places where word
the word does not appear
in the text message and one in places
where the word appears in the text
message
it doesn't matter how many times it
appears the question is does it appear
once or more
yes question
we're going to talk about it right um
so here um x
is so if our vocabulary has d
dimensions right so if this count is d
then x belongs to 0 1
to the power d this is how we write
a d dimensional vector where each
element is either zero or one
right and any given x j
is either zero or one
right and you make the assumption
at p of x j
and we write out our model like this so
this is our model
just as the way in case of the gaussian
ah discriminant analysis
we we had a hierarchical model that
described how the data was generated
similarly we are going to have a model
here p of
y equals 1
equals v y
and p of x j
given y equals 0 equals
phi of j given y equals zero
right so we are going to assume that
there is one
bernoulli distribution parameterized by
phi
y where phi subscript y is one value
between 0 and 1 and that's the parameter
of this bernoulli distribution
which tells us what fraction of our
overall text messages
are spammy versus not right it's just
the class prior
and then we have two
sets or two collections of bernoulli
variables
one set for the class y equals zero
so for y equals zero we have a vj for
each j from 1 to d
which tells us what's the probability
that x j
equals 1 when the class is 0
and another set of bernoulli variables a
full set of binomial variables
corresponding to y equals 1 which tells
us what's the probability that
x j equals 1 when the class is 1.
so what the what this means is what's
the probability
that this word the word um corresponding
to the index j
will show up in an email
that is spammy and this tells you what's
the probability that
a word indexed by j shows up in a email
or text message that is
not spammy this question
so what's the number of parameters here
so here we have
one parameter here we have
technically we have d minus one
parameters
oh no so here we have d parameters and
here also we have
d parameters so two d plus one
parameters
good question ah does it make sense we
have one parameter to
to ah give us the class priors whether
just you know what
in the entire population what fraction
of messages are spammy versus not
and then condition on you know by
limiting ourselves to say
only the spammy emails then we have um
one parameter for each word that tells
us the probability that the word will
appear in
a spammy email or the probability that
it will appear in non-spammy
yes
so there are d such distributions for
each chip
so j can be from 1 to d so you have
d such bernoulli distributions
now there are two different sets of
variables right two different sets of
distributions
right and for this ah so this is our
model
and we can write out the
likelihood function for p
of y v of
j given y equals 0 phi of
j given y equals 1. so basically think
of this as
this is one parameter this is a set of d
parameters
this is another set of d parameters and
the likelihood
can now be written as probability
of or the log probability i equals one
to n
p of x i
y i
given the full set um v and this can now
be written as
i equals one to n
p of y i
given p of y i
v of y times
product j equals one
to d p
of x j i
given y
i v
right and the way we can we can um
we came up with this term as the product
of all the different uh
xjs is using the the conditional
independence assumption
what that basically the way we came up
with that is p of
say x 1 x 2
x d given y this is p of x given y
can be written using a chain rule as p
of
x 1 given y times
p of x 2 given
x 1 comma y times
p of x 3 given x 1 comma
x 2 comma y and so on
and with the conditional independent
assumption each of this becomes
p of x 1 given y and with the
conditional
or independent assumption this becomes p
of x 2 given y
and this becomes p of x 3 given y
and so on and this product is what's
written here
right so you know just the way
the iid assumption allows us to factor
out different exam
the the probability or the likelihood of
uh
the probability of the full data uh into
product of the
individual probabilities similarly
conditional independence allows us to
break down um
this full uh collection given y as
you know the product of the individuals
right so this is the likelihood
and each of these we know is a bernoulli
and we know the probability density of a
bernoulli
plug them in take the gradient
take the partials with respect to each
parameter set it equal to zero
and by doing that we get the maximum
likelihood estimates
m l e estimates
phi j given y equals
1 is equal to
i equals 1 to n
x j
1.
right what does this mean the
probability that the the word
belonging to the jet index in the
dictionary
is is is uh
the probability that the jth word in the
in the in the vocabulary
is going to show up in a spammy email is
equal to the number of times
the word appears in spammy emails
divided by the total number of spam
emails
right this expression looks a little
cryptic but it's actually pretty simple
what it's doing is it is you scan over
every email or every text message i
equals 1 to n
and count the number of times
or count the number of text messages
where the jth word appears and
the message is spammy and divided by the
total number of
emails total number of text messages
that are spamming
is just calculating in what fraction of
the spammy emails does the jth word
appear
right the syntax looks a little cryptic
but you know it's
the the idea is very simple this
question
this p so this p is basically the full
collection i've just
written it as v
it's 2 d plus 1.
yeah so yeah so um and similarly uh
phi j given y equals 0
is equal to same story i equals 1 to n
indicator x i
j equals 1 and so this is the logical
and
right and y
i equals 0 divided by
equals one to n
indicator y i equals zero
right and finally phi y
is equal to i equals 1 to n
indicator y i equals
1 divided by n right
so the v y parameter is estimated as
the number of spammy messages divided by
n
right and each for each class of you
know
spammy versus not spammy you get a full
collection of bernoullis
per word and they are estimated as the
number of
the number of messages in which the word
appears
divided by the total number of messages
in that class and it's the same
definition here
but we just switch y equals 1 here this
question
this one so here we just broke down
the joint into the factors right so
think of you know
we start with this joint and you can
write this
as p of
x i given y i times p
of y i
right
and and this one
we factorize it using the conditional
independence assumption
right so this this is just this is just
the factorization of this
by making use of the conditional
assumption conditional independence is
up here
yeah this parameterized by phi of y yeah
what does conditional assumption mean
here it means
when you know whether when a message is
spammy
then the probability of word
a appearing is independent of whether
word be appeared or not in it
yeah so if certain words always appear
together
it does violate the conditional
independence assumption
but we're just going to make that
assumption anyways just to make the math
simple
yes
yes this ignores the order in which the
words come yes
yes spammy email
some words are not necessarily spammy
right like words like the and are not
necessarily spammy
but what we see is that by by making
this assumption
and uh by the this this
um um this set of assumptions
generally tends to work well in practice
even though you know there are
um the the intuition there is that if a
word
um has no significance in terms of its
indicative power
then it's going to contribute equally to
both the classes and its effect kind of
cancels out that's the intuition to have
like common words
are will have equal weight in those in
in
for both classes but words that have a
high
[Music]
indicator power of spamminess will
will will bump up the class probability
higher
right so that is the maximum likelihood
and from this how do we make predictions
now
so we follow mle and we estimate all the
parameters
and once we have ah estimate the
we're going to make predictions using
the bayes rule
so the base rule tells us p of y equals
one
given x is equal to p of
x given y
p of y given x times
p of y um
divided by p of x
and this is equal to p of x given
y times p
of y over p of
x given y equals 0 times p
equals 0 plus
now to make predictions on a new email
x you're going to first convert it into
a feature vector
of d dimensions and we're going to
calculate these terms
um so p of y
we estimated uh the and here we're just
going to use
you know phi y um and this is basically
the product i equals
1 j equals 1 to d
x j
i given y
times p of y
divided by the denominator
right and using again again using the
conditional independence assumption we
can break down
the the uh the long vector of of
the feature vector of the new email into
product
of the individual bernoullis
right and multiplied by the class
probability we get
the probability of of p of y equals 1.
so
we do p of y equals 1 given
x equals and similarly you can calculate
p of
y equals 0 given x to be
the same thing with but um
denominator right and in order to make a
prediction
um what's commonly done is you calculate
numerator one
and you calculate numerator two and see
which of the two two numerators is
bigger than the other
all right so um
one problem that we may encounter with
this method
so any questions on this so far yes
question
so these two add up to one once you
calculate the denominator
and normalize them they will add up to
one but just the two numerators need not
add up to one
yeah if you want to get the probability
value then you need to
then you need to calculate the
denominator but if all what you want is
to make a decision of which of the two
has a higher probability then you don't
need to calculate the denominator
so one problem that ah we may encounter
with this method
is what happens if
at test time we encounter a word
that was never seen in the training set
right so our um
so in this model
what if the word say artwork never
showed up in our training set
neither in positive examples nor
negative examples
and we end up estimating the
fees for the word artwork to be 0 and 0
because the numerator is 0 in both the
places and at test time
what do we do at test time it means
for the word artwork at test time you're
going to end up
with 0 over 0 plus 0 because this is
going to be 0
if the word artwork appears in the email
um the
the the probability corresponding to the
word hard work will make
the entire thing equal to 0 and
similarly you know this will also
factorize and the word artwork will make
this 0 this 0 and you're going to get a
0 over 0
when you encounter words that you have
not seen before so basically with this
with with this method
a problem is if we encounter
a message at test time that has a word
that never appeared in the training set
either as class one or s class two
we we the method does not tell us
what our prediction should be right
and for that ah
what is commonly done is a technique
called laplace smoothing
so laplace moving was
invented by laplace
and the
the origins of the plus smoothing was is
um go something like this so laplace was
basically trying to calculate
the probability what what's the
probability that the sun is going to
rise tomorrow what's the probability
that the sun is going to rise the next
day
right and in your training set you
basically have only positive examples
right so every day in you know if you
look at the past 100 days or thousand
days you start
collecting your data right every day the
sun is rising
right and in your um so your training
set um has
only positive examples and now when you
estimate the probability
of what of the sun rising the next day
your mle estimates will give you a
probability equal to one
right it will always be exactly equal to
one
and uh his claim was was that um
that's that is suboptimal right it's it
the the probability that the sun will
rise the next day
at some day in the future is going to be
zero might be you know the sun may not
rise
uh you know uh uh someday and so
um he invented with uh the the the
correction that he came up with is
commonly called as laplace smoothing
and the idea of laplace moving is
supposing you have um let's say you're
doing coin tosses
right so let's say you're trying to
estimate um the bias of a coin let's
call it fee
and uh your x's are zero and one
now you t you take a coin you know flip
it ten times
and let's say the uh the the coin
turns up heads all the uh for all the 10
ah
for all the 10 trials what is our
estimate of fee in that case
if phi is supposed to be probability of
heads
so right so the mle estimate tells us
that this is going to be 10 over 10
and ah and so uh our parameter would be
the fee would be one but what laplace
smoothing tells you is the way to kind
of
think about that is
let's say you um you're you're
conducting
you're keeping two counts sorry
count of heads and count of tails
right in pure maximum likelihood
we start with the two counts being zero
and as we keep conducting trials
we add a one
and so on and then we
sum up the count
h over sum over count
h plus sum over count tail
right what laplace smoothing tells us is
before we
even start conducting our experiments
start with a count of one for all your
classes
right assume a uniform probability
before we start conducting our
experiment
and then start your trials and observing
data
and incrementing the counts right
and with this technique we see that
because we start with a count of 1 on
both sides
even if all our 10 experiments
come up with a plus 1 the probability of
heads
in this method will be 10 over
right it will never be exactly one and
similarly the probability of tails
will keep going down as we collect more
data it's going to start with
0.5 and as we keep running experiments
and
and the probability and we keep getting
only heads
this keeps coming down right but it will
never be exactly zero
right this is the this is the idea of
laplace smoothing
and this laplace smoothing
can be applied to our
spam classifier as well right so assume
that we have seen every word
once in a spammy email and once in a
non-spammy email
right initialize your counts to that and
then
start observing your data and and
accounting for your data so the laplace
smooth version
of
right so the laplace smooth version
of our estimates will be like this
so for comparison here is the maximum
likelihood estimate
and the laplace mode estimate would be v
j given y equals 1 equals
1 plus sum over i equals 1
to n x j
i equals 1 and y
i equals 1 divided by
2 plus sum over
n
right so the idea here is you add one
to your to the count and you
add the number of classes in your
problem
to the denominator so you add 1 to the
numerator to say you've seen
that word at least once and you divided
by 2
for to to account for the fact that
that this evaluates for probability a
valid probability density
a valid probability distribution
right and similarly the laplace smooth
version
of j given y equals 0 will be 1 plus
so this component in the denominator
comes from the data
the number of messages which are spammy
and then you assume you've seen two more
messages
one message in which the word appear and
one message in which the word did not
appear
right and over here since this is the
probability that the word appears
you assume you've seen the word appear
in one message
and also in the rest of the messages
where the word actually appear
right that's the idea of laplace
smoothing right
and this is um if you're familiar with
bayesian statistics this is like
imposing a beta prior on your parameters
if you don't know what that is
don't bother but um it's it's not not
only is it just a heuristic
heuristic argument there's also a
principled explanation of why this is a
good thing to do
all right so that's laplace smoothing
and now we um
and this this this model is what is also
called as the
bernoulli event model
and there is another variant of naive
bayes
which is called the multinomial event
model
right so in the multinomial event model
which is a slight variation of this
which means
a lot of the terminology is going to
show up here but may mean slightly
different things
so please pay attention it is it is a
slightly different model
which makes a different set of
assumptions and the assumption it makes
is that
you know y again comes from a bernoulli
parameter fee but then
each word in your email which is either
you know
which is either spammy or not spammy so
x given y equals 0
is sampled from a multinomial
well so the correct is actually
categorical
is comes from a categorical distribution
and we are going to still call it phi
except now phi is a d
dimensional categorical
parameter vector in fact here it will be
so this is
one dimensional phi of y
and phi of k given y equals 0
will be d
let's not call it d will be
the size of your vocabulary minus 1
dimension
what does this mean now so first i'm
going to write
out the expressions and then you know
give you some intuitions about this
[Applause]
right so the
so the mle estimates here
look like this v
k giving y equals one
right here the assumption is that here x
now indicate x j indicates the word in
the j
position of the of your text message and
that can be
that is a word with that exists in your
dictionary so v
or is the vocabulary and
this means the size of your vocabulary
so
xj or the jth word in a message takes a
value between one and
the size of your vocabulary and x i
which is the
ith message is the full full message of
your
ayat example is has length d
i so each message can have a different
length
right and x i is now
a vector of length d i where each
component can take
one of the words in our vocabulary right
now the maximum likelihood estimate for
this model
will save phi of k where k is the word
in the vocabulary is
given by this term where you're summing
over every every message
and within each message you're summing
over every word and counting
only those words in those messages which
happen to be k
and belong to the class that we are
interested in
and divided by the total number of words
across all messages in that class right
and similarly phi of k
given y equals 0 equals
basically the same thing just replace y
equals 1 by y equals 0
right and you can also have a laplace
smooth version of this
i am going to write out the laplace mode
version and then you know give some more
intuitions about this
v k given y equals 1
equals 1 plus
i equals 1 to n j equals 1 to d
i
x i j
plus k and y equals
1 divided by the vocabulary size
plus
right so this is the ah similarly you
have a
phi k given y equals 0
equals you know a similar thing just
replace y equals 1 with 0.
and the um the way to think about these
the ah the bernoulli event model and the
multinomial event model
is to probably
look at how an algorithmic
implementation of
of these two models would look like
so supposing we have a training set let
us call this you know
buy our lottery
and
buy this watch
right you have a few examples and let's
say you also have
a non-spammy example for example
when is your exam
or when is the homework due
right now um
first let us look at the bernoulli
so in the bernoulli we convert this into
a fixed length vector
where you we have a
[Music]
hard work
by exam
and so on and what we do is
what we do is for each example
we we use an indicator variable to say
whether
you know the word appear or not
right similarly here it's going to buy
and there is going to be a watch
you know and zeros everywhere right so
this is the fixed length representation
which is
d dimensional where d is the is the size
of your dictionary so the way you want
to think about this is
in case of the bernoulli model first
we're going to convert a given message
into a multi-hot vector which means it
is one in multiple places
the word may appear many times in this
in a given message but we count it only
once
right so uh maybe to clarify this
buy this watch this watch only
right and
we then and we do this repeat the same
thing for the
non-spammy so here we will have you know
exam will be one you know yar will be
one
the others will be zero and similarly
this will be a few places
right so we have a set of
spamming examples and a set of
non-spammy examples
right and for each of these two
different classes we have
a separate collection of bernoullis
per word so we have one bernoulli
for the word a one bernoulli for the
word aardvark
one bernoulli for the word by and each
of these bernoullis
is estimated by summing over the number
of times
the word has a 1 divided by the number
of words in that class
similarly over here another set
of bernoulli so this is 5 say 5 j
5 j for y equals 1
this is phi j for y equals 0.
and each of these 5 js you just count
the fraction of
the fraction of words the fraction of
messages in which the word appears
divided by the number of messages
and similarly the fraction here this
will be 1 over 2
this will be 2 over 2 and so on
right this is the bernoulli model
that we discussed first and similarly
the multinomial however is a little
different
the multinomial right if you were to
implement this algorithmically right
assume you have the same set of words
here a
hard work by
exam and so on in this case however
instead of
using an indicator just count the number
of times the word appears
right so 0
0 you know y is 1 lottery is one
over here again buy is one watch is two
so this is watch what was zero here
you know only is one whatever right
and now we do the same normalization
by summing up the counts so the number
of times
the word appeared across all examples
in your training set right whereas over
here it was the number of
messages or number of examples in which
the word appeared
here it is the number of times the word
appeared across all messages
right that's the main difference between
the bernoulli model and the multinomial
model
and so here our so we're going to
sum up the counts so here it's going to
be 2 2
2 and maybe some of them it is 3 it is
4.
in the bernoulli model each one of them
was its
own bernoulli variable so we normalized
it locally
right in the multinomial model we want a
distribution over words
so we're going to normalize this entire
thing by
summing over 4 plus 2 plus 3 plus 2
plus 2. right so the
the multinomial model gives us a
distribution over words
of how frequently that word appears in
spammy messages or non-spammy messages
and it doesn't care about whether the
word appears a thousand times in one
message
or appears once in a thousand different
messages the multinomial model doesn't
care
the bernoulli model however
counts what fraction of the messages has
this word
the bernoulli model cares it doesn't
care how many times the word
appeared in a message it's just going to
count it once per word once per message
right and when you apply laplace
smoothing
what it basically does is you add
two messages
one message has zero everywhere
and one message has one everywhere
right and then renormalize it locally
you get the laplace smooth version of
the bernoulli event model
similarly you know you extend the zeros
here
one message one message that has no
words and one message that has all the
words
and they normalize it you get the
laplace smooth version of
the multinomial event model
any questions yes questions
so the question is if there is if there
is one um
if there is one spammy message that has
a spammy word repeated ten thousand
times but does not appear in any other
message
then this model will update that word
like quite a lot
this model will will think that you know
there's just one message with that word
that's the main difference
[Music]
so in this in this model um it does it
it is just summing up the words you know
so one way to think about this model is
take all your spammy messages
concatenate it into one long example
use you get the same model even if you
have one message that's a concatenation
of all your
you know messages whereas with this
you're counting how many
number of messages a word appears and
that's the main difference between the
two
yes
here you're only uh summing up
right so only the second one will sum up
plus v
right when when you add up all these you
know the
you know you're getting zeros over here
and here you're getting
one per word so that's that's what gives
you the plus
b
so um so the laplace smooth version we
have a plus
you know we are adding the number the
the vocabulary size
to the denominator right and that is
basically achieved
uh because you're adding a plus one per
word
so there are you know v such words
and when you when you sum up you know
the when you sum up
all the counts here you get a plus v in
the denominator
so by so uh the laplace smooth version
of y will be in this case
2 plus 1 3 over
the original count whatever it was
plus v right it is going to be
this is 2 plus 1.
so it without laplace smoothing it was 2
plus the original count
now it's going to be 2 plus 1 because
you got 1
from the new message and plus v in the
denominator because every word got one
sum of all the words here you're summing
over all the number of words right so
over here
you're summing over the number of words
in your spam class or the number of
words in your non-spam class
yes questions
yeah so the idea is you know these
counts may all be ones or all be zeros
and you don't want them to dominate so
you add a zero and a one for each word
so with laplace smoothing we add one
positive
and one negative per word one positive
and one negative per word
all right uh i think we're over time so
that's about it if you have any more
questions you know feel free to walk up
and
um i can answer them
you